hey Jason Miller is senior
communications advisor for the Trump
campaign Jason we're glad to have you at
the table good morning think so a couple
things what would be your definition of
success tonight for mr. Trump and what
makes you look at him and say he is
ready for this battle this evening I
think if mr. Trump is able to come out
and show that he's the one who's gonna
get our economy back on track he's gonna
keep us safe he's gonna want to make
sure we're gonna go and renegotiate
these bad trade deals he'll stop illegal
immigration he's able to convey that
message the same things have been
carrying him so well in the polls were
seen it with the crowds were seen with
the energy coming into this week they'll
be success but those are all talking
points I want to get to the nitty-gritty
of what you see in him tonight that make
you know that he is on fire and ready to
take on Hillary Clinton's one to one
ninety minutes no break so I think
tonight we will see is it mr. Trump is
ready to be commander in chief and this
is the chance where voters have seen the
commercials a lot more from Hillary side
they say 250 million dollars that dumped
on mr. Trump's had but they'll see the
candidates up there at the same time on
the stage together and I think what
they'll see is one candidate is very
comfortable in his own skin is ready to
be commander in chief and I thready he's
going to be a change agent so what is
really going to change our country take
us in the right direction and I'll be
stacked up against Secretary Clinton and
she'll be presenting her vision in a
much different direction what's on his
list of things not to do I would say you
know I think tonight as long as he's
talking about his message and he's
focused he's talked about the contrast
between the two the vision he wants to
go vs where Hilary wants to go and I
think that's going to be a win I think
here's the thing for mr. Trump coming
into tonight is that he's a candidate
he's not a politician he's somebody
who's not been he hasn't been doing this
for 30 years he's not so nice to pull
test and blow-dry every single answer is
coming forward if Charlie's Charlie's
question one of the things that mr.
Trump even here has said and he takes
great pride he's a counter-puncher he
punches back when challenged has has the
campaign talked about how they may do
that tonight is he going to counterpunch
he'll be ready for tonight never
underestimate Donald Trump okay let's
just ask this though is he preparing not
by the way she might be praying with his
thick briefing books but looking for
some psychological insight well the one
thing that we've seen this is more on
the the staff and this as lures as we
discuss as a team and getting things
getting things
together as it was Secretary Clinton
she'll do great in her first answer
we'll see her first answer in each of
these six sections she'll hit a home run
it will be programmed I'll have been
pulled I'll being tested out where
Secretary Clinton runs into trouble or
in the second and third answers where
become more variables commander there's
interaction between the candidates
that's where she runs into trouble that
it's recently whether he has a second
and third answered that he is not deep
in terms of policy he is primarily deep
in terms of a broad statement like I'll
build a wall oh it's mr. Trump he's
actually gone laid out a number of
policies in this campaign how to get the
economy going how to stop illegal
immigration he's the one who actually
has the policies if you go to his
website you'll see that he's laid out
very detailed plans great piece in The
Wall Street Journal today on that point
and you'll see me you'll see tremendous
amount of substance you see a remarkable
clarity and again when we start getting
in these second and third questions
because after the openings for each
candidate you have this back and forth
is 10 minutes section and that's where
Hillary starts running into trouble is
because you can't go and pull test all
the way through these things where they
allowed to question each other there'll
be some back and forth but it's will be
largely driven by the moderator and
where is it that voters normally make up
their mind in the first 10 to 15 minutes
there will be a lot of people watching
on Twitter you concerned about that
because no 90 minute break you can't go
in breaks and say well what you need to
do here is where she got you there and
maybe you might want to go back to this
no worries concerns about that mr.
Trump's going to come out and he'll talk
about his vision so again the great
thing about mr. Trump is he's not the
politician he's going to be the same
person wherever you see him and whatever
he's talking about and so that's what's
so great about going into the debate is
that's why you're seeing the energy
you're seeing the crowd you're seeing
the poll numbers reflecting those great
numbers so that we've seen from other
networks this morning have you all had
mock debates so again we have not had
someone stand in is a Hillary Clinton
that's because mr. Trump has remained
very focused on what does he want to
talk about in this debate was he want to
communicate to the American people thank
you Jesus thank you give you good thank
you and a reminder have you heard
there's a debate tonight you can wash it
right here on CBS our live coverage you
begins at night Eastern 8 at nine
Eastern 8 central